make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Robin
I'm getting ready to crash out for the
night I'm getting ready to go to bed but
before I do we are covering x-men part 6
yes we are the conclusion of the x-men
story or at least the first story arc of
x-men by Jonathan Hickman so this is
pretty solid but what it does is it
requires us to kind of line back to
house and powers of X right it all those
kind of wraps back around to the
beginning of everything and how it all
sort of started and the way this picks
up is it is it sort of jumps to the past
right at some point in the past there
was a kind of discussion that took place
between Irene Adler and a mystique now
for those of you guys who don't know
Irene Adler is also somebody by the name
of destiny and you've probably heard of
what are called destinies books or
destinies Diaries that was part of an
extreme x-men story from 2001 the hunt
for Destiny's Diaries which is actually
pretty cool right this idea that she
wrote 13 books which basically detailed
what was gonna happen in the future but
Irene Adler originally appeared back in
uncanny x-men issue number 141 right so
she was basically introduced as part of
the Days of Future Passed saga and then
from there she was really kind of
brought in as essentially this love
interest and wife of mystique why the
two of them fell in love the two of them
had a relationship and it was pretty
solid it's one of those things that only
for hardcore x-men fans do you really
know about it it's really pretty obscure
right and even destiny herself is pretty
obscure in relations like the greater
comic book landscape but the long and
short of this is that she ultimately
ended up dying and uncanny x-men issue
number 255 basically the two of them
were always kind of like the one-two
punch of what was essentially the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants in Marvel
Comics after the events of magneto
basically leaving Matt and freedom
forces what destiny ends up saying is
that she's got something to tell
mystique like I have something to tell
you but before we find out what it is we
jump to the here and now and what this
shows us is that work is still being
done by orcas now again those are guys
who were playing catch-up from house and
powers of XM and I highly suggest that
you guys go and check out my playlist on
the x-men which you'll find down in the
description and it'll get you totally
caught up on pretty much everything
going on but orcas is kind of like this
anti-mutant organization more or less it
basically composes or is or is composed
of a lot of organizations right so Hydra
has a hand in it the let's say the
advanced idea mechanics groups has a
hand in it all kinds of different groups
right the only group that I do not
believe is involved in orcas or the
purifiers although I could be wrong
but the overall gist behind this is that
if you guys recall in the events of
house and powers of X ah that the x-men
had basically launched an attack against
the Orcas corporation in order to
destroyed mother mold and mother mold
was basically a a giant Sentinel that
was going to produce master molds and
master molds in turn produce the regular
signals that you guys are used to seeing
and what this would do or at least what
it would have done had it you know been
successful is it would have led to the
development of sentinels and at a
geometric rate right it would have just
been insane how fast the signal
production would have been ramped up by
humanity and so in order to keep that
from happening and really kind of under
the information provided then buy more
make a guru to the various lives that
she's lived over you know the ten
timelines whatever the case is she ended
up you know the exponent of traveling to
two or CRA's corporation and then in
turn basically you know taking out
mother mold which and you know letting
it crash into the Sun but also resulted
in all of their deaths right and so what
we end up having here is a guy by a guy
by the name of dr. Devo right or dr. dev
oh you know however it is it that you
that you want to pronounce it although I
guess it's really director demo it's
really what it is but anyway he's the
guy overseen the whole Orchestra
operation and of course working on a
device this device is taken directly to
dr. Greger now dr. Greger if you guys
recall was the woman who lost her
husband during the x-men strike on Orcas
station right so for her it's not really
about you know the possibility of a
mutant threat for now for her it's now
like a personal vendetta is really what
it is right as is a personal vendetta
against the x-men and so what we end up
finding out here at least the way things
look is of course she's kind of building
this this sort of sort of chassis but
before we really find out what it is
what we end up doing is jumping back to
to the plans that were basically being
made with regards to mystique and with
Charles Xavier and the the mission that
was going to take place with regards to
Orcus space and now if you guys again
this is one of those important stories
because it kind of bounces back and
forth you know with housing powers of X
but the the idea behind this is that
when Xavier and company initially went
to to mystique and basically said like
we want you to be on this mission but
because we want you to serve a
particular purpose the question was what
is this purpose and ultimately they said
we want you to plant a seed and so this
is kind of some of the behind the scenes
stuff that we did not initially see when
we were reading house and powers of X
and remember that's the nature of
Jonathan Hickman
right hitman ER will do a thing you're
he'll write a part of
story and then he'll leave part of it
out right and then like later on down
the line you'll figure out what that
part of the story was and why it's
important right so there can be a lot of
bouncing around and a lot of shuffling
and things along those lines but the
idea was to plant a seed seemingly a
door uh Kirk Owen Gateway on the ship
that nobody was going to know about and
this is when we basically ended up
picking up with mystique during the
events of passing power Lomax when she
was killed right when she was basically
sucked out of an airlock and it
basically seemed to be the end of her
and it's kind of a funny thing because
then of course to basically pick up with
the resurrection of mystique and then
that's what she essentially gets him to
the deal that was being made right the
idea that if she agreed to work
alongside Charles Xavier and Magneto
that she would be given something in
turn and the question is what is it that
she was supposed to give right what is
this she was supposed to essentially get
you know as a result of working along
with them and it's one of these funny
things right because when they're
talking you know Xavier kind of says you
know uh basically like we're we're
grateful for everything that you've done
but ultimately we need more and that's
really kind of one of the the issue that
you get when it comes to Xavier and
Magneto in their current state is yes
they're operating on a greater authority
that authority coming from Warren
McTaggart who's basically said I've
experienced multiple timelines they all
into the same way this is the way for us
to change things that kind of stuff but
it also brings in a lot of humorous a
lot of arrogance right the whole we know
better than you do kind of attitude
which could really cause a lot of
problems especially when you're dealing
with somebody like a mystique because
for all the glitz and glamor and all the
talk they basically have mystique is one
of the best people to bring in on their
side because she's lived for hundreds of
years rush she's been she's been around
longer than Wolverine has right so she's
an exceedingly old character but the
idea is that she also has a lot of
experience under her but she's been a
good guy she's been a bad guy you know
when she when she let freedom force it
was a US government sanctioned team
right they basically went out and saved
mutants from anti-mutant groups right it
was a it was really done like in
exchange for pardons right you know for
them to basically be given pardons from
their actions as as a brotherhood
because that's what freedom force was
just the reformed Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants but when they're having this
whole conversation what they're
basically doing at least the initial
question of mystique is okay if this
gate didn't work then what happens if I
try to walk to it right because the
issue is that she died before her
actions could be recorded by cerebro
right so if you guys are called what
Hickman's established here is that death
doesn't really exist anymore
right any mutant that dies can be
brought back and it's not done for the
purpose of just being like all weird
is whatever you know it's being done by
basically saying it serves a purpose
right there's a reason behind why this
happened but one of the things that's
been going on here is that with the the
x-men of various mutants who are being
sent on missions their minds are always
backed up and so should they return from
that mission the information they have
is backed up in cerebro so the x-men or
really the mutant population always has
an updated database on what's going on
around the world with the various
missions that are being undertaken and
things like that and so the result is
that with mystique
her mind was not backed up before she
died right so there was no way to know
if she had successfully planted the
device plan of the Gateway on kokoa and
because it was such a secret mission no
one was supposed to know about it right
so it's not like you know they can go to
Jean Grey and say hey like can you can
you tell us whether or not she planted
that gateway because not even Jean Grey
knew that it was gonna be going off
right like nobody knew but this is being
done by Xavier magneto through mystique
and so ultimately when she ends up you
know Donnie an outfit and passing
through she ends up finding out yes it
worked exactly like you were supposed to
and that's when she comes to the
realization of what's actually going on
right the idea here that was essentially
been taking place is that where it was
believed that the mother mold was
essentially going to create master mold
which in turn was going to create
signals who in turn would create Nimrods
ultimately that's not what happened that
instead Nimrods were manufactured by
humans directly they were created
explicitly
by human beings they were not created by
sentinels and that was the big error
that was being discovered here at the
idea that nimrod is is essentially being
designed and and isn't really functional
yet but will be and is functioning or at
least is being built on the Orcas
station so humans are developing these
ultra sentinels right and it kind of
makes sense right it makes sense to kind
of create these signals that are
virtually indestructible because that's
one of the things about Nimrod is Nimrod
has the ability to sense the inherent
weaknesses of the mutant sees facing off
against so then of course also you know
know what their powers are just by
tapping into the Sentinel database he
has a whole host of different abilities
right shape-shifting different things
like that but he's one of the most
dangerous threats out there Nimrod is
exceedingly powerful and so that's one
of the big things is because when you
end up having this go down they
initially try to get mystique to go back
in and it basically you know destroy the
Nimrod program or whatever the case is
but her response is no and the reason
why is because she wants destiny to come
back and that was the deal that was made
the deal that was made by Xavier and
Magneto is if you do this for us we'll
bring back
destiny and so ultimately when mystique
tries to barter a mystery tries to get
them to bring her back ultimately they
don't there is kind like no like like
you need to do for us like we'll bring
her back
once you've earned it right like once
you've earned the right to have destiny
returned to you then it will be done and
that's why we end up gently with this
that's where we end up jumping into the
conversation between destiny and
mystique right this is probably one of
the single most important things to go
on here what destiny basically says is
she says you know sometime you know
sometime in the future I'm going to die
like I'm gonna die prematurely before I
grow old or anything like that you know
I'll die before old age takes me but
there will also come a point many years
after that or there will be an island
but in on this island there will be
mutants who were who were inhabiting
there and and they will make a deal with
you in order to bring me back but
ultimately they're never going to hold
true to their deal right they're gonna
do everything they can to deny you my
return right like in order for this that
you know and in this instance when this
time comes like what I want you to do is
to bring me back right like bring me
back do not let me stay dead but like
bring me back because the the ultimate
idea is that those individuals want us
to be blind they want us to be blind and
in to follow their plan without any
question whatsoever what this does is it
hits the idea and we don't really know
whether or not you know destinies being
the Furious here there's really no
reason to believe she is what she's
basically establishing here is the idea
that Charles Xavier and Magneto are
essentially you know of course of being
dubious for a being mysterious but
they're not really looking out for the
overall betterment of mutant con well
that's not really what they're shooting
for there's some kind of alternative
plan going on here presumably the mutant
population could be used as cannon
fodder and whatever happens to them
happens today but having a precognitive
like destiny show up on the scene would
essentially disrupt all their plans
because destiny is well known to the
mutant population right even to the
world population shield knows who she is
the Avengers know who she is
everybody know who knows who destiny was
right and so would that being the case
when she shows back up if she shows back
up immediately her precognitive
abilities are gonna be recognized as for
the most part absolute and if she comes
along as you says guys everything that
you've been told is wrong here's what's
actually going to happen people will
listen to her and they'll really kind of
begin ignoring Charles Xavier and
Magneto which can cause all kinds of
problems right so the return of Destiny
could be cool but it could also cause
some fries
things to take place but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rod poor if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
ok I want to give a shout out to Kyle be
David Joseph Ben John h aj matt in jeff
our john h lean and mean which is an
awesome name jason see austin s austin a
Joey M Steven Z Austin B Adam K and
Genesis 9:6 team you remember guys you
can sit me messages and I'll run off
whatever your message is at the end of
the video so long there's nothing crazy
but if you want to put a message in
there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch it guys
[Music]
[Music]